on va dans la rue on s'habille comme les
gens pendant à peu près pendant qu'il
répondait aux questions cd inédit des
tout nouveaux regarder tout nouveau sein
d'une équipe qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens des
transports en commun parisiens
il marche très bien normalement et votre
réponse quoi mon frère j'ai pas j'ai pas
de frère d'ange r je suis enfermé j'ai
eu un accident de cheval à 12 ans qui
m'a ça toi tu penses quoi de la doré rer
a
mais mes moustaches tout ça la camisa
negra personnes et papel el cartel de
cali
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
personnellement je les prends pas trop
et votre heure ils en pensent quoi mon
frère aujourd'hui pas à okc
ça
c'est vrai
que penses tu des des transports on les
prend pas nos potes on festoche tu crois
aux et doit faire bah non c'est juste on
se ressemble en fait on est c'est le
hasard quoi ouf
1 il ya un truc c'est dingue ok je
retour à notre dame des landes
on m'attend les gars ça dit qu'est ce
que vous pensez de transports en commun
parisiens
ça aide beaucoup malheureusement est
quand même certains soucis je peux
comprendre que dans certains cas bas il
ya besoin que ce soit réglé mais je
pense que il ya quand même un manque de
communication envers les utilisateurs et
votre elle en pense quoi
je n'ai pas de frère pardon je n'ai pas
de frère salut bonjour
sa patte et body dont windows à tout ce
qui vous fait ont posé des questions à
votre frère
on n'a pas le temps là je voulais je
fais bouillir dans les sims à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]